and we could go and have a uh a nuclear
war which would uh not only kill a lot
of people what would poison a lot of the
planet and i don't think humanity would
be erased but it would be like a you
know biblical setback what about going
inner earth then to hide from it and
what about what about what about inner
earth people no there's no inner earth
people i mean like if you have to go
inside the earth to wait out the storm
why didn't couldn't somebody else have
done that yeah but there's no sunlight
down there there's no food like how do
you grow anything how do you get what if
they have their own ark and the ark
makes some light
sanica you know if you think there's a
bunch of morlocks hanging around down
there walking around in their secret
underground chambers
to me first of all let's just think
about it this way if you were one of
these underground people who the hell
would want to live underground why
wouldn't you just come up through a
sewer grate and be like enough of this i
want to be out here where it's sunny i
think the teenage mutant ninja turtles
did that